[Música]
boa tarde já sabe que sou antônio vieira
no umbigo minha idade mas digo ano
comecei meu 9 certo de 41 se em casa dos
meus pais agricultores e foi por aí que
eu comecei a minha vida profissional
tenhamos assim entrei nessa universidade
não não quero mentir mundo mas aos 34
anos já está lá escrito nessa um livro
assinado por aí eo ao set e teve que ir
ao escola primária que durou quatro anos
porque eu não tenho nenhum era burro mas
quatro anos 4ª classe porque eu sempre
teve não gostava muito da escola eu não
gostava da escola mas sempre tive a
ideia porque quando a gente estava
metido e algum trabalho era para cumprir
então procurei cumprir sete anos saiu
aos 11 dos dos homens e aos 21 são os
poucos de anos e eu não agarrar e um
lápis nenhum livro todo esse tempo foi
de curso universitário e não era
remunerado
eu passei todos esses anos sem um tostão
porque naquele tempo eram temas das
questões saiam dois tons
mas eu também não tenha o maior herói
eu não tenho dinheiro porque não tinha
tempo para gastar
porque se a trabalhar e em nosso nome é
nascido chegaram a casa já havia solo
tal ordem era para descansar para
começar o outro dia e assim
o 21 fui ao cortelli 30 meses no quartel
sempre quando vinha de férias xi o fim
de semana era a mesma lei ensinado sair
do cortelli aos 30 meses passavam para
mesas
talvez algumas dicas arm fábricas lá é
porque a gente busca sempre uma
companheira não é e como já não
estávamos chamado namorando há sete anos
pode ele já estava longe
a tap uma fotografia penso eu ea minha
mulher hoje foi de vestido curto
porquê para quê tanta pantalha vivo eu
porque éramos se éramos 1 mil dos
agricultores do estilo curto por opção
por ser abandonada do marido pronto
[Aplausos]
quando me casei
os meus pais para executar dar para
possivelmente pagaram todo esse tempo
nunca tinha tido total
os meus pais eram bem cinco escudos 1 a
como a minha mulher era filha só os
jogos eram agricultores
eu fui ver ele para casa dos meus jogos
à parte da casa em um dos jogos que
fazia parte para a agricultura
estava já muito velha chovia por todo
lado
eu já tenha dinheiro no bolso de desfile
vamos recuperar toda esta parte e
recuperámos em dois anos seguintes e
chorou prova a quando terminou a
recuperar essa parte agrícola como todos
aspiramos terem uma camiseta de seu
órgão chove olha que eu vou fazer uma
camiseta pra mim e eles não contrariaram
e eu fui fazer a minha camiseta e já
estava outra vez na mesma não tinha
dinheiro
lá fui vendo dinheiro para ele levantar
a camiseta porque antes das casas
levantávamos comissão do polis erse e
depois fazendo pra cima
hoje na hoje ou a visto que começam a
fazer a casa pelo telhado e depois será
o que deus quiser
e tal como eu estava perdidinho dinheiro
está claro tenha que pagar sempre aquela
idéia é que seja em torno por outro lado
leste a se consegue uma vida melhor
então resolveu emigrar para bruno ela
que tinha lá uma irmatov tornado de s
emigrei para manuela mas nesse tempo
estava proibida a entrada na minha visão
de entrada mas como na terra tudo se faz
um senhor advogado lá conseguir uma
entrada legal porém 11 mirim bolívares
daquele tempo no ano 70 milhões
eu cheguei a trabalhar nessa padaria que
era do meu cunhado e eles que naquele
tempo na isso pagava mas eles pagavam já
ordenado vôo naquele tempo me money mais
por mês ea mesma dava comida e domina e
eu fiquei no mesmo problema já não tinha
dinheiro outra vez e também não tinha
tempo prepararmos gastá lo porque eu
começava a trabalhar às 6 da manhã e
terminava à uma da manhã do outro dia
tem ali umas duas horas livres pra comer
e descansar um documento e por aí passei
até terminar de pagar essa dívida tinha
deixado uma ca e chego lá já tem outro
em 1º deve pagar até lá porque quem
estava pela urss
e tal por aí esteve nessa padaria e
depois resolvi comprar uma outra padre
gazeta pequena com um sócio uma padaria
que pouco todo trabalhado e trabalhei os
314 no record logo depois quando estava
nessa padaria velho 25 na ilha chamada
livro ordem e eu como já tenha sete anos
que não bem acordou ali porque a minha
mulher quando minha filha nasceu porque
passei um candidato por cima quando eu
sei ele a mulher estava engraçada a
minha mulher é ter uma menina essa
menina nasceu no dia 4 de dezembro e o
país soube que tenham uma ceia no dia 31
de dezembro porque ela não era como
agora era quarteto 31 de dezembro ecosul
que teve uma filha
então assim a ganhar meses ea minha
mulher foi ter comigo e deixei cada dois
rapazes que eram os mais velhos da
padaria não foi inventada mas alguma
coisa deu como eu sempre gostei muito da
agricultura caiu outra vez ou mesmo
falar naquela altura estava a funcionar
há quem no programa de leite leiteiro e
eu comprei umas batatas torneadas e por
aí foi
mas não tinha dinheiro outra vez compra
de um trator zito ea jazz sempre foi a
falta de dinheiro
pensei pedir um crédito ao banco e
estava sempre já tinha conhecido então
o coraçãozinho estava lá no ano no 79
morreu a minha querida mãe no dia do
santo no ano 81 morreu o pai então já
não tinha o cheiro mais próximos mais
queridos então passado os meses decidi
ir outra vez a venezuela
deixei a minha mulher e os meus filhos
caco as quatro equipas que ainda havia
e lá vou eu próprio joelho trabalhar
outra vez num balcão de padaria nós não
foi na mesma foi nota
e aí trabalhei um par de meses depois
apareceu me um negócio jeitão kasten
zito pequeno era aí a galera aí quatro
por quatro
vendia cafés e ramos são do dinheiro
fresco mas nela mas o cafezinho de
maneira bastante
eu começava a essa carta é às cinco da
manhã por cozinha quando começo a china
pela manhã já não corria banho e até às
nove já não fazia outra coisa era sempre
café
as novas tenham um espinheiro dos cafés
entre pequenos e grandes tirados por que
será servido em e coop do plástico
o êxito foi produtivo era produtivo que
teme nenhuma jeito cínico como saber
quando estava nesse negócio êxito
a padaria onde eu cheguei
os donos querem uma sociedade resolveu
arrendá lo
eu fui falar com um dos donos de quando
cheguei e já havia dois pretendentes
para além da padaria e eu cheguei eles
vão deixar obra já está acima mencionada
já por vales e agora é passado
mas espera aí vamos ver aguentaram os
outros tiveram maturidade a mente por
alguma coisa foi nos saímos pra uma
coisa foi então trabalhei essa padaria
um anô como renda tarde o fim do ano
eles desenvolveram vender o que é
comércio mas a caa construção da padaria
era própria nessa mesma série
e eu disse olha só a padaria não compro
como todo padaria e casa e lá vai outra
vez o mesmo problema
não há dinheiro
este pobre o meio do servidor tenha 300
mil e um cunhado me custou 400 já tinha
claro milhão faltavam 300
esses 300 praia português e italiano um
lado toda a gente conhecia falando com
um amigo português aqui da palhaça e
disse olha passa assim a gente olha se é
por dois ou três meses
quem presta o time mas me sinto nele
para uma inversão que vou fazer
o elenco profissional eu não conseguir
paranaense milhãozito inicial de r 1
milhão inicial e ficar a dever e os três
melhores a 50 mil cada mês d'água para
cinco anos
dadá não deu para cinco anos 60 meses
nunca fez tais letras no comércio
vejo que ele está a pagar mesmo ali não
confirmei mas todos os meses de apagar a
um dos sócios porque eles eram cinco e
apagar e nunca teve receio nenhum em que
gostava do 50 ml e assim se passaram
cinco anos cinco anos e quando chegou o
último mês de mocinho assim pronto
preocupa já está pago por aqui às vezes
não se vê muito isso mas lá existe a
seriedade assim essa padaria cozinha
farinha no mínimo que isso se está a ver
na fotografia tenha 16 empregados mais
ou menos dependerá da temporada
à venda na fabricação e no local
eu nunca me considerei patron de toda
aquela gente sinal um companheiro de
trabalho só tenha outras possibilidades
agora patrão nunca conseguirei patrão
nessa mesma época padaria lá na sigla me
uma associação de parelheiros e eu com
esta humildade e os outros para eles me
empurraram para presidente da associação
por isso já fui presidente
[Aplausos]
mas sempre nunca pensando muito alto
sempre passando mas shittu como digo
naquela padaria nunca me senti padrão e
o tempo vai passando de pareia metemos
um outro negócio por lá que não foi
muito bem quase fica em outra vez com
uma atrás da outra frente que era minha
família assim será o herói dinheiro e
depois contavam os amigos consegui sair
dessa situação e viajei por do vale do
ivaí as de ficar não foi corrido nem
assustado nem nada
hoje lá montado nem voz nem voto na ala
mas o coração zito está no joelho e eu
sei pra que eu posso ou chega e faz
agora um ano e vamos ver quando agora se
será o próximo este será mais para
frente porque na venezuela não tendo
nada nada ganhou voz nem voto
há também uma forma de evitá-la no hu o
dinheiro da 30 cêntimos por mês
o animal é a mesma mas pronto chegando
lá sinto muito ricos em nada e
trancou na mão para o futuro do rio
branco
eu não quero eu não quero terminar a ser
baixa sem deixarmos o mar
o meio da mensagem sempre que possam e
queiram na vida procurei ser trabalhador
chão primeiro sérios
o segundo tento e poupados porque da
poupança alguma coisa vai ficar muito e
repito nunca pensou em construir a casa
por um criado o motor ligado
[Aplausos]